pam it's michael help me i need help
right now michael what's wrong i'm hurt
i have hurt myself
oh my god okay wait wait
michael do you need me to call an
ambulance no i want you to pick me up
okay
wait a second i thought you said that
you were hurt i am hurt i'm sorry
i want to come to work but i need you to
come and pick me up
no god hey whoa michael oh god it's okay
it's jim just say again really loudly uh
what happened okay
i burned my foot
very badly on my foreman grill and i now
need someone to come and bring me into
work you burned your foot on a foreman
grill
i enjoy having breakfast in bed i like
waking up to the smell of bacon sue me
and since i don't have a butler i have
to do it myself
so
most nights before i go to bed i will
lay six strips of bacon out on my george
foreman grill
then i go to sleep
when i wake up i plug in the grill i go
back to sleep again
then i wake up to the smell of crackling
bacon
it is delicious it's good for me it's a
perfect way to start the day
today i got up i stepped onto the grill
and i clamped down on my foot that's it
i don't see what's so hard to believe
about that
michael right
the chocolate powder just went down my
throat i'm stopping now is this why
you're calling me no no no no no no
i'm calling
i'm sorry
okay
i'm calling because
i'm an early bird and i'm a night owl so
i'm wise
and i have worms
oh
oh breakfast i got your sausage egg and
cheese biscuit yummy yummy thank you
ryan
what was the thing uh you needed me to
come in early for
um
the sausage egg and cheese biscuit
but thank you and why don't you just
take a couple hours off this is yours
home alone risky business take your
pants off run around
or you ought to do
i'm just going to take a nap in my car
till work starts okay
okay
healthier
i'll watch those cards
dunder mifflin this is aaron
he's not available right now
uh-huh
yes
sure i'll give the message when he gets
up gets back
michael had chicken pot pie for lunch
actually let me rephrase that michael
had an entire
chicken pot pie for lunch
let me be more specific michael ate an
entire family-sized chicken pot pie for
lunch and then he promptly fell asleep
so we're all trying to be very quiet so
as to not wake him up before 5 p.m which
actually should be in about
ten minutes
okay i'm gonna go in there and change
the computer are you sure you can change
this watch i can do it what do you need
from me
normally i don't condone leaving early
but i have an appointment with the horse
doctor
how that horse became a doctor i don't
know
[Laughter]
no i'm kidding he's just a regular
doctor who shoots your horse in the head
when his leg is broken
like clockwork
[Laughter]
[Music]
[Laughter]
oh wow okay
all right let's all go home come on
see you all to molly
you later michael
there will be complimentary pretzels
available in the lobby from now until
four o'clock as a thank you to our loyal
tenants
once a year they bring in a little cart
and they give away free pretzels it's
really not a big deal
to some people it is
productivity is important but how can i
be productive if i have this one little
thing in my brain that i cannot get out
and that one little thing is a soft
pretzel
so i'm just gonna have my soft pretzel
i'll get to work and i'm gonna be super
productive look out for me
oh shh
come on
thank you hi please tell me you have a
sweet pretzel left we do
and we have 18 different toppings we
have sweet glaze cinnamon sugar
chocolate white chocolate fudge m ms
caramel dip mint chip chocolate chip
marshmallows nuts toffee nuts coconut
peanut butter drizzle oreo sprinkles
cotton candy bits and powdered sugar
is there any way that you could do all
all of them the works you got it all
right
thank you
that's interesting
wow it's a little early for ice cream
it's never too early for ice cream gem
but we didn't have any ice cream
so this is mayonnaise and black olives
oh it's comfort food all right
god yo michael this old donna thing is
gonna be okay you just stop beating
yourself up i know well i hope you're
right we'll see what dwight says why do
we have to see what dwight says because
i have him investigating her i'm waiting
for a text up michael no no no no no no
undo that undo that it's too late to
undo it i need to know otherwise this
thing is going to spiral out of a muck
michael okay i'm i'm going to talk
straight to you because i think you need
to hear it michael this is so disgusting
stop eating it do you want to be happy
look at you you have a major
self-destructive streak in you
and you
you kind of torpedo every romantic
relationship you're in that's not true
they're right i ruin everything
and i've known some wonderful women
holly carol
jan helene
colleen my mother oh
my mother helene oh yeah yes yes yes all
of all of the greatest loves of my life
you should
stop this
you excited
everybody freaking out mm-hmm cool gonna
be fun you're late thank you but i
forgive you because doffit is my
birthday
what's up
hey
oh happy birthday ah thank you sir
michael's birthday uh it's pretty fun to
watch actually
he gets very excited and then he eats a
lot of cake and then he runs around the
office then he has a sugar crash in the
afternoon and then he falls asleep
and that's when we get our work done
somebody brought in donuts for my
birthday
happy birthday thanks
who brought in donuts somebody got
donuts for my birthday
happy birthday you didn't know it was my
birthday i guess i forgot well i guess i
forgot to give you a donut
you're serious hmm
[Music]
stop what is that
that's for the longest time by william
joel what's your favorite song yeah when
i saw the radio my birthday blows
nobody even signed my birthday poster
apparently my mother
is the only one who cares enough to send
me anything i probably care more than
she does you're making it worse
i bet luke perry's friends don't treat
him like this
okay
wendy
hot and juicy redhead
let's give this a try
wendy's
hello
wendy this is kevin's friend michael
this isn't wendy oh i'm sorry could you
put her on please dude this is a wendy's
restaurant
kevin okay um
could i just have a frosty and a baked
potato please you have to come to the
restaurant to order food well i'll send
somebody to pick it up just have it
ready and it's ready now
well put it aside
you